bherwani congratulations
you can find
this album in the neighbor dollars excess
growth was boiling represents
reggaeton itself
for me really to be grateful
to the last one that has been sent for me
a pleasure to be able to represent the musicians
the banna reggaeton track and hop the one I
listen to my  disco por siempre knows that
there is everything, it is an album that I made
with a lot of love, with a lot of love,
we try to give the worlds to people a
little bit of creativity, a little bit of lyrics
and really, for me I will always
represent the music
of  puerto rico
because don latina whatever we are
here we get to live for and
with deep and ricky martin in resident
your eyes smith 5 with my work with this
way wow imagine for me super great
just collaborating with them but in the
way that  It was that we got together in the
studio, everything came out quite naturally, everyone
has returned to the subject and now for
singing it live for the first time, all
together in the celebration of  the 20th
anniversary of the latin grammys is something that
i will always carry in my memory at
a time that i want to enjoy not
sometimes the lav is required for rich
but without wings and records
benito
they are all great music three moonmen in
huachipa  present
the option of streets that are
more of a type of stress
demanding pressure and then indigenous is ready
in a matter of life after that it is very small that is
why I have heard that no
thanks from Vélez I I I have simply
said it I always do my job
what my work is what I am passionate about they
understand me I just do what fills me up I
try to please people they
tried to please me to be me
generally to do what I
want
I am blessed that I can do
everything  that what I can think of and
that not everything never has the limit and that
is what I do and that people connect
with me and get inspired for me is a super
bastard show I do not have the intention of
changing the world but yes yes  it  achieved
from avilés pérez with it's on it like
way of acting and sporting ex john white
cold
for me always the future and
independent obviously nobody knows
what in the future I am I live day by
day obviously we are going to make
music raising the game we come  with a couple
of things it's worth a surprise for people
so nothing
to break as always death walking
ford an action day the guild tour
is super bowl the world wears judges
ministers and of course latinas and state and
that for me is super big they are not only
that they be Latina but also women,
Latina women representing the
entire community, so I am
really proud
that the world now everyone is
alone when we have made Latinos
so proud
[Music]